low-lying Bangladesh is on the frontline
of climate change its farmlands facing
constant floods erosion and salinity to
combat these farmers are using rafts
which remains a flawed for a period long
enough to grow vegetables the problem is
during high tide this air gets flooded
with little water remains during low
tide this is why we're using floating
beds to grow vegetables floating
platforms offer up to an additional 40
percent of arable land creating
opportunities for poor landless farmers
aquatic farming essential practice in
Bangladesh that almost disappeared is
making a comeback with limited land
resources and threats of climate change
people here are now starting to
appreciate the importance of
environmentally friendly traditional
cultivation systems mahomet new jehan
can earn around two dollars fifty cents
for day's work we use organic
fertilizers on these seeds then keep
them in a shaded area to mature later we
plant them in the floating beds with
natural fertilizers and sell them and
ready in the markets farmers generally
do not use chemical fertilizer or
pesticides using this method so there's
a greater demand for them these plants
and vegetables are from the floating
bids farmers bring them to us by boats
we then carry them again and boats in
selamat various bazaars this year
floating seed beds have been used on 290
hectares of parasport marshland area
there are now around 50,000 people
involved directly or indirectly in this
type of farming in the district the
Indian s are about leadership this
method of farming is getting really
popular and is now practiced in at least
15 to 20 other districts farmers are
making a good profit on many poor
Bangladeshi farmers have now been given
a financial lifeline by turning back the
clock and relying once again on a
traditional farming technique to protect
their livelihoods sandwhich Audrey
al-jazeera pirata pool southwest
Bangladesh